à 60 km de kiev la voiture de ce couple
s'arrête soudainement sur la route un
char vient d'apparaître au loin la
frappe est immédiat
ces images de vidéosurveillance film il
ya une dizaine de jours viennent d'être
révélés le char fait demi tour et repart
le véhicule est pulvérisé le conducteur
et sa passagère calcinés depuis l'armée
russe continue chaque jour possible et
des civils
aujourd'hui à jitomir c'est un immeuble
qui a été bombardé la ville est pilonnée
depuis plusieurs jours c'est l'un des
verrou stratégique à 150 km à l'ouest de
pierre
à l'opposé de la capitale la région de
soumis à l'est a également été frappé
cette nuit des raids aériens ont détruit
des maisons de ce quartier résidentiel
les secouristes s'affairent à évacuer
des blessés
dans la région de kharkiv la deuxième
ville du pays c'est un hôpital qui a été
visé le bâtiment qui venait d'être
construit vite ce n'est plus qu'un champ
de ruines à poltava seule lueur d'espoir
les premiers bus est vacant les civils
dans les couloirs humanitaires sont
arrivés dans la nuit la fin d'un
cauchemar pour ses habitants qui ont pu
laisser derrière
mes parents j'ai laissé
sans nourriture sans eau
mais à tchernobyl autour de la centrale
désormais contrôlé par l'armée russe et
l'inquiétude les systèmes permettant de
surveiller à distance les matériaux
nucléaires ont cessé de transmettre des
données à l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie atomique
sur le plan diplomatique le président
ukrainien se dit prêt aujourd'hui dans
une interview à discuter avec vladimir
poutine du statut de la crimée et des
républiques séparatistes
discuter sur l'avenir de ces territoires
nous avons compris que l'otan n'est pas
prête à accepter l'ukraine quand je vois
l'alliance train la confrontation avec
la route
de son côté moscou dit constater des
progrès dans les négociations menées
avec l'ukraine en affirmant que
l'objectif de la russie n'est pas de
détruire le pays